et non ceci n'est pas une oeuvre d'art
même si effectivement visuellement c'est
très joli et que ça a même inspiré des
vêtements à la Fashion Week c'est en
fait tout bonnement le meilleur
graphique pour illustrer le
réchauffement climatique on appelle ça
des crocs tripes donc des bandes du
climat on va donc l'analyser ensemble et
je vous garantis qu'à l'issue de cette
vidéo et bien vous comprendrez mieux que
jamais ce dont on parle réellement qu'on
en parle de changement climatique avant
de commencer très rapidement un petit
mot concernant notre partenaire qui nous
soutient aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si
vous le savez mais le choix de votre
banque peut avoir un impact positif ou
négatif pour la planète en fait l'argent
sur nos comptes ne dort pas et les
banques l'utilisent pour financer
différents projets certaines banques
décident de prêter leur argent à des
projets polluants comme sellier aux
énergies fossiles par exemple mais
d'autres banques refusent et c'est le
cas des lios qui nous soutient donc en
étant partenaire de cette vidéo et qui
en fait la banque française avec le plus
faible impact carbone selon le rapport
2022 de greenly alors j'ai d'ailleurs
moi-même à titre personnel incompte et
j'en suis très satisfait en fait c'est
une Ecobank qui s'engage pour la planète
car elle soutient des projets qui
accélèrent la transition écologique
grâce à votre argent elle vous permet
aussi de suivre directement sur
l'application comment votre argent a été
utilisé et plus généralement en fait
l'application est super bien faite pour
suivre toutes vos opérations et comme
c'est le cas sur moi et que votre compte
actuel vous pouvez payer avec une réelle
carte bancaire avec une carte virtuelle
sur votre téléphone ou alors par
virement alors si mais ça vous intéresse
vous pouvez créer un compte en moins de
10 minutes en ligne c'est très simple et
j'ai d'ailleurs un code promo qui vous
offre les frais bancaires pendant les
trois premiers mois sur les comptes
courants jeunes et communs le lien est
donc directement en description et on
peut commencer la vidéo et on commence
donc avec ce graphique dont je vous
parlais à l'instant des climat Stripes
ce graphique il a été popularisé par le
climatologue britannique aide Hawkins
qui a voulu faire comprendre en fait le
réchauffement classique avec un visuel
très simple concrètement c'est un
enchaînement de bandes de couleurs alors
comment ça se lit concrètement c'est
très simple en fait plus la température
sur cette année a été élevé par rapport
à la moyenne entre 1970 et 2000 plus la
bande et rouge et à l'inverse plus la
température sur cette année a été basse
et bien plus la bande est bleue ce que
l'on voit donc ici c'est une
accélération très rapide du
réchauffement des températures sur les
10 20 dernières années toutes les bandes
rouges sont sur la droite et toutes les
années les plus chaudes donc sont parmi
les plus récentes c'est en fait une
représentation plus visuelle de ce
graphique là qui est peut-être beaucoup
moins connu sous forme de courbe disons
plus classique en fait les huit années
les plus chaudes de l'histoire ont
toutes été enregistré c'est vite
dernières années selon l'Organisation
météorologique mondiale aujourd'hui la
température a déjà augmenté d'1,2 degrés
en moyenne par rapport à 1850 il faut
noter d'ailleurs que le GIEC donc le
groupe d'experts de l'Organisation des
Nations Unies sur le climat viens de
publier dans son dernier rapport dont on
vous a parlé une version de ce graphique
tournée vers l'avenir selon donc les
différents scénarios de réchauffement du
scénario le plus optimiste en bas au
scénario le plus pessimiste en haut et
vous le voyez donc ici dans tous les
scénarios malheureusement la courbe vire
clairement au rouge et les années les
plus chaudes actuellement seront les
plus fraîches dans 30 ans bref la
planète se réchauffe de plus en plus
vite c'est indéniable mais alors
pourquoi et bien ça a commencé avec un
gros changement aux alentours de 1850
avec ce que l'on appelle la révolution
industrielle en fait à la fin du 19e
siècle et au début du 20e siècle on
s'est mis à exploiter massivement
d'abord du charbon puis du pétrole et
aussi du gaz c'est ce que l'on appelle
des énergies fossiles puisqu'elles sont
issues en fait d'une lente décomposition
d'anciennes matières vivantes dans le
sol pendant des des millions d'années on
sait donc rendu compte que ces énergies
pouvaient démultiplier notre puissance
nous permettre de nous chauffer de nous
déplacer plus vite de construire
n'importe quoi très rapidement autrement
dit dans cette période de recherche de
croissance économique d'augmentation de
la production de compétition entre les
différents états et bien les besoins en
énergie ont tout simplement explosé il
se tourne encore et toujours aujourd'hui
vers les énergies fossiles dont
l'utilisation ne fait qu'augmenter bon
et augmenter en fait c'est beaucoup trop
faible comme terme cette consommation
elle a réellement explosé vous le voyez
sur ce graphique mais alors quel est le
problème avec ces énergies fossiles vous
me direz et bien ce charbon ce gaz
pétrole lors de leur extraction puis de
leur combustion il libère dans l'air
massivement du CO2 le CO2 on en a
beaucoup entendu parler évidemment c'est
l'un des principaux gaz à effet de serre
et le résultat de cette consommation
massive d'énergie fossiles c'est donc
une explosion
c'est même grâce à lui en fait qu'il y a
de la vie sur Terre sans aucun gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère la
température serait de moins 18 degrés et
la terre serait véritablement un bloc de
glace donc heureusement qu'il y a cet
effet de serre mais vous l'aurez compris
aujourd'hui il y a un petit problème
justement avec cet effet de serre en
gros les gaz à effet de serre
naturellement présents dans l'atmosphère
autour de la terre absorbe une partie
des rayonnements du soleil pourront
conserver en fait une partie de la
chaleur le truc c'est que la hausse de
la concentration de ces gaz à effet de
serre provoquer donc par les activités
humaines et par ses émissions de CO2 et
bien ça amplifié le phénomène d'effet de
serre et ça a donc conduit à une hausse
très importante des températures l'effet
de serre en soit est une bonne chose
pour l'humanité mais certainement pas
dans les quantités actuelles bref
normalement là vous avez compris d'où
vient le réchauffement climatique nous
avons en tant qu'humain fait appel
massivement aux énergies fossiles et on
a déréglé donc des équilibres en place
depuis très longtemps mais du coup que
faire et bien reprenons le même
graphique que tout à l'heure celui sur
la consommation d'énergie à travers les
années mais voyons dans le détail quelle
énergie est utilisée aujourd'hui le
charbon le pétrole et le gaz sont encore
à l'origine de plus de 75% de l'énergie
que l'on consomme dans le monde et la
France elle aussi est concernée par
cette dépendance et oui on entend
parfois que la France elle n'est pas
concernée par l'utilisation d'énergie
fossile car elle a le nucléaire en
réalité c'est assez trompeur oui
effectivement le nucléaire joue un rôle
très important sur bien la production
d'électricité puisque près de 70% de
l'électricité en France et d'origine
nucléaire et donc et bien c'est une
énergie qui produit très très peu de gaz
à effet de serre mais ce n'est pas vrai
du tout pour l'énergie en général au
delà donc de l'électricité l'électricité
c'est finalement qu'une petite partie de
l'énergie finale qui est consommée sans
environ un quart en France et trois
quarts restants de notre consommation
d'énergie et bien c'est la combustion
directe des énergies fossiles sans
transformation donc préalable en
électricité alors très concrètement
parce que là j'en suis conscience peut
paraître un peu flou mais ça peut être
l'essence de nos voitures ça peut être
le kérosène de nos avions ça peut être
le diesel de nos camions et d'une partie
de notre train ou encore le gaz et le
fioul de nos chaudières le gaz et le
charbon de l'industrie etc etc résultat
donc quand on regarde ce que l'on
appelle la consommation d'énergie
primaire en France en 2020 ça fait donc
que près de 50% via des énergies
fossiles le pétrole le gaz et le charbon
résultat et sans parler de la question
de l'uranium ou autre pour le nucléaire
je pense que ça fera l'objet d'autres
vidéos sur la chaîne bien oui les
énergies fossiles ont encore un rôle
très important en France ok donc on voit
qu'il y a un réchauffement climatique on
voit que l'humanité est responsable on
sait aussi que c'est lié principalement
aux énergies fossiles mais alors qui est
vraiment responsable et bien ce
graphique il représente les émissions de
CO2 par pays en 2021 on voit donc que la
Chine est aujourd'hui de loin le plus
gros émetteur de la planète avec 31% des
émissions globales devant les États-Unis
qui sont à 14 % des émissions ou encore
l'Union européenne donc la France
notamment qui sont à 9,8% des émissions
si on prend ceux des comptes très
classiques qu'on va nuancer après mais
donc avec celui-ci la France compte pour
0,8% des émissions avec 1% de la
population mondiale alors qu'à côté de
ça le continent africain par exemple
représente 4% des émissions de CO2 pour
17% de la population mondiale donc à
priori si on le voit comme ça et bien la
France est bête très peu de CO2 mais
là-dessus il faut apporter de très
grosses nuances à ce qu'on voit ici
première nuance importante et ce
graphique le montre c'est que
historiquement ce sont les États-Unis et
les pays européens qui sont responsables
de la plus grosse partie des émissions
pour dire les choses très simplement les
États-Unis ou encore les pays européens
dont la France ont commencé à polluer
beaucoup plus tôt que la Chine et c'est
important de le dire car le changement
climatique c'est le reflet de
l'accumulation de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
au cours du temps autrement dit oui la
Chine est certes responsable aujourd'hui
de 30% des émissions de CO2 sur l'année
2021 mais elle n'est responsable entre
guillemets que de 14% des émissions de
CO2 accumulées depuis 1850 et à
l'inverse d'ailleurs pour que vous
compreniez bien du côté des États-Unis
et bien c'est 14 % des émissions en 2021
mais près de 25% des émissions en cumulé
et donc pour la France même logique
c'est 0,8% des émissions en 2021 mais
c'est 2,3% des émissions de CO2
accumulées depuis 1850 la deuxième chose
très importante qu'il faut noter c'est
que là quand on parle de 0,8% des
émissions en France on parle des
émissions sur le territoire national
français mais ça en réalité c'est très
trompeur puisque on passe notre temps à
importer des produits qui viennent
d'autres pays comme par exemple donc la
Chine qui est supposément donc le plus
gros pays émetteur si par exemple vous
avez acheté je sais pas moi un téléphone
qui a été produit en Chine bien ce
téléphone ou alors une partie de vos
vêtements ils sont pas comptés comme une
émission française alors que c'est un
produit qui est important et acheter
parfois par des Français autrement dit
donc aujourd'hui on délocalise en
quelque sorte une grande partie de nos
émissions en fait la bonne manière de
mesurer véritablement notre impact sur
le changement climatique c'est avec un
chiffre que l'on appelle l'empreinte
carbone pareil peut-être que c'est
quelque chose dont vous êtes déjà
entendu parler qui inclut les
importations et les exportations et en
regardant l'impact carbone et bien les
émissions de CO2 moyenne de chaque
Français chaque année monte à 10 tonnes
et 10 tonnes en l'occurrence et bien
c'est bien au dessus de la moyenne
mondiale pour espérer limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 2 degrés
maximum il faudrait qu'un Français
émette moins de deux tonnes d'équivalent
CO2 par an soit 5 fois moins
qu'aujourd'hui en moyenne et 2 degrés
c'est un chiffre clé quand on parle de
climat c'est en fait l'objectif que ce
sont fixé les pays du monde à Paris en
2015 lors de la COP 21 limiter le
réchauffement climatique nettement en
dessous de 2 degrés et si possible à 1,5
degrés mais aujourd'hui on est encore
très loin en fait aujourd'hui on se
dirige vers un réchauffement climatique
global entre 2,5 et 2,9 degrés selon
l'organisme climat action tracker qui
recense en fait toutes les politiques
qui sont prises dans les différents pays
du monde la courbe bleue montre elle la
réduction des émissions de CO2 qu'il
faudrait entreprendre tandis que la
courbe en verre montre les réductions
d'émissions de CO2 qu'il faudrait faire
pour limiter le réchauffement à 1,5
degrés ça voudrait dire donc diviser par
deux nos émissions d'ici 2030 c'est
quelque chose d'absolument massif alors
que vous le voyez en comparaison la
baisse des émissions de l'année 2020 ou
une grande partie du monde a été
confinée pendant des mois en raison du
covid n'est que de 7 ampleur bref sans
action massive et très importante dès
maintenant on se dirige vers un
réchauffement climatique très important
et d'ailleurs ce sera un réchauffement
encore plus important en France près de
4 degrés au rythme actuel en effet le
réchauffement climatique n'est pas
uniforme dans tous les pays du monde je
vous parlais tout à l'heure des 1,2
degrés de réchauffement qui ont déjà été
attendre le monde en France par exemple
on est déjà sur une augmentation de 1,7
degrés selon le dernier rapport du GIEC
bon dernière élément important que je
vous transmettre dans cette première
vidéo sur le changement climatique
quelles vont être les conséquences et
bien ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que 1 2 3 4 degrés c'est pas simplement
une question de sortir en t-shirt en
automne ou alors de d'arrêter de mettre
des doudounes en hiver en réalité de
tels changements d'un point de vue
climatique ont un impact absolument
colossal pour vous donner un exemple de
ce que ça représente 4 degrés et bien 4
degrés en moins c'était le climat en
Europe il y a 20 000 ans à cette époque
seulement 100 000 humains ils vivaient
dans des conditions hostiles avec 5
degrés en moins la tête de notre
continent était complètement différente
l'océan était 120 mètres plus bas et une
grande partie de l'Europe était
recouverte d'une couche de glace bref
quelques degrés de plus ou de moins ça
paraît peu dit comme ça mais en réalité
les conséquences peuvent être immenses
mais là-dessus pas d'inquiétude j'ai
prévu avec mon équipe une vidéo qui vous
expliquera plus en détail les
conséquences potentielles de toutes ces
augmentations de température on se
plongera donc beaucoup plus en détail
dans tout ça mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que il y aura une
intensification et une multiplication
notamment et bien d'épisode extrêmes ça
peut être des canicules ça peut être des
incendies ça peut être des sécheresses
comme on voit d'ailleurs déjà en ce
moment ça peut être aussi une quasi
disparition de la neige en moyenne
montagne là aussi c'est quelque chose
qui est déjà actuel ou encore une hausse
du niveau de la mer avec des
conséquences très importantes qui peut y
avoir et encore là je on va rentrer dans
les détails des questions concernant la
biodiversité bon les conséquences on va
rentrer en détail dans une autre vidéo
on fera aussi une autre vidéo concernant
les moyens d'action donc analyser quel
peut être le rôle des citoyens des États
ou encore des entreprises une vidéo
peut-être un peu plus positive entre
guillemets parce qu'on va être porté sur
les solutions et voir donc comment agir
concrètement en tout cas en guise de
conclusion chez vous ne devez retenir
qu'une seule chose c'est celle-ci on
aimait actuellement beaucoup trop de CO2
ça tous les scientifiques le disent
aujourd'hui et c'est dû à notre mode de
vie à nos modes de consommation et à nos
modes de production alors je vous mets
des ressources directement en
description si vous voulez en savoir
plus par ailleurs vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais on a deux chaînes
YouTube une chaîne dédiée aux actus du
jour qu'on fait chaque jour du lundi au
vendredi et une chaîne dédiée donc à des
plus longs formats comme celui-ci si
jamais vous n'êtes pas encore abonné du
coup pour nous soutenir dans notre
travail vous pouvez tout simplement vous
abonner on approche du million d'abonnés
donc merci du fond du coeur pour votre
confiance je sais que vous êtes nombreux
à ne pas être encore abonné donc
n'hésitez pas à le faire je tiens à
remercier Paul qui a trahi avec moi sur
l'écriture j'attends vos retours dans
les commentaires merci à Elio c'est
encore une fois d'avoir été partenaire
aujourd'hui de toutes les infos sont en
description prenez soin de vous prenez
soin de nos proches et puis je vous dis
à très vite